back with Brooke Shields my dear friend
and in your new movie Holiday Harmony
you're a car mechanic and don't even get
me started because I'm so obsessed with
them and alpaca owner yeah and and they
it was so interesting because I had to
work with these alpacas and they they
weren't trained alpacas
so I literally had to spend time with
these alpacas to get them to trust me
and how did you do that I just was
really calm really quiet and they do
this thing called
and I was like oh God and you don't know
if they're gonna go crazy or not they're
so sweet anyway it was really fun doing
a movie where I'm like dirty all the
time and and have a slight accent and
I'm with alpacas but Christmas we the
Christmas song at the end of this movie
is like you it does not get better than
this and it's a love story it is
annalize the the lead of of the show and
she's she's just she's got a voice of an
Angel and she's so sweet and I'm a
sucker for Christmas movies I love
watching them being in them I'm just you
know they're just they're feel good
listen
there is a large industry that relies on
this time of the year as their big money
makers I mean Christmas movies are very
important to people all right so the
skims campaign we got to get into it
[Applause]
when you shot the nothing comes between
my calvins 15. I mean you look the same
no thank you like identically the same
the whole thing was so quick but it was
so empowering and it was it was just
empowering on a on a very large level
what was scary to me was that normally I
have this sort of way of getting
prepared for something and you kind of
go a little if you know you have to fit
into something it's not my normal side
you kind of go into I'm going to work
out I'm gonna eat better for three weeks
and a little biting shape fighting shape
I had no time
and I just thought you know what stop
judging yourself listen to the music go
just act as if get lost in the fantasy
yeah as if you know you when you see
confidence because you can see
insecurity and when you see confidence
even if you have to fake it I had to
fake it until I I made it and it I was
doing it in real time and I thought okay
get your posture right walk out as if
you've always deserved to be here and
you know I felt like I was in a train
wreck by the end of it because I got on
that plane and I thought what just
happened you know but I was such a it
was an honor and I'm I'm gonna it's an
honor that I keep getting asked back
anywhere
Kim herself dm'd me the next day really
there was a human piece to it that that
probably shocked me more than than the
fact that I had the guts at all to get
in underwear after this one right there
I can't say in her DM I'd love to know
because I'm I'm just so fascinated by
her and you know she's really just made
everything of herself there's no one
handing her anything she is making it
happen she dmed me this message and she
was like you know I just wanted to say
thank you we were so excited and I it
was such an honor and I said say hi to
your mom and you know I mean I don't
know her and you know I know how to work
a position and yeah good light and
they've got hair and makeup people and
it's like they do everything that they
care ever I mean that was like I didn't
want to wash my hair for that I need to
know I will tell you what okay please do
um yeah exactly it was designed to make
you look good you know also I mean it's
from my perspective when during the
pandemic I really I had such an aha
moment and I I'm 57 but
thank you
um but when when a woman turns a certain
age that it's like the world goes you're
done you're good okay if you've raised
the kids you're at work we're good we're
gonna put you out to pasture and by the
way hell no and I I thought to myself
I need to create a community I need to
build a wellness brand for women over 40
who are becoming empty nesters who are
trying to get back into a Workforce but
they don't even know what they want to
do and we need to inspire them and so I
built this Wellness brand called
beginning is now so that's what that's
what that's what that experience for me
was I thought okay yeah you know you're
not you don't look like you did at 15
but I don't want to be 15 anymore but I
wanna I wanna be the best I can be now
and I want other women to feel that and
I think it's worth risking putting
yourself out there knowing everything
you're going to get back is not all 100
positive nobody gets that in life I
don't care where or who you are but risk
putting yourself out there to ingratiate
others to to Brook's Point lift each
other up and I just your behavior your
mindset your heart you've always been
just such a shining example of how a
human being should operate in this world
and I just love you more and thank you
for coming on today I love you this is
so much fun
check out holiday Harmony because it
premieres this Thursday on HBO Max
[Music]